welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is future villains are a true empty
slate other than like a team of fake
news VFX artists and a pile of dust in
the shape of Thanos
but there is one villain who many argue
never got his proper do Ultron
since his apparent destruction at the
hands of vision many have speculated the
AI presence may still be alive nestled
into our webcams taken notes and now
that vision last we saw is a gray husk
gathering rest in the wakandan jungle
could we be going by dodgeball rules
here does that mean Ultron's back in
well recently Marvel Studios released a
trailer for The Avengers damage control
VR game which features a parallel
storyline of the MCU and the voices of
the MCU actors including Leticia right
as Sheree Benedict Cumberbatch's Doctor
Strange bengaline Lily as wasp Paul Rudd
as ant-man and it sounds like Tom
Holland as spider-man and James Spader
is Ultron or voice actors who do very
good impersonations a powerful threat
has resurfaced I sense that this Force
has been waiting rebuilding its strength
and secret until now
are you guys the new recruits
now to be clear this game isn't
confirmed to be MCU canon it's just a
high-stakes hypothetical scenario to
help you feel like a badass and sure you
designed armor as you fight alongside
the Avengers but the return of Ultron
alongside the voices of the other
Avengers is a big deal because this
arrives after a long history of clues
Easter eggs loose ends that have been
hinted that Ultron could still be alive
throughout the MCU films since age of
Ultron waiting rebuilding his strength
and secret I'm gonna explain all those
details and the crazy ways Marvel could
actually bring Ultron back in this
special update episode of inside Marvel
okay let's begin by returning to the
final act of Avengers age of Ultron is
right after Ultron having hijacked a
twin jet tried to kill Hawkeye and that
kid but Quicksilver intercepted the fire
and dropped yet Hulk jumped into the
Quinjet tossed Ultron out Scarlet Witch
finds Ultron and rips his heart out of
his chest
then when the sokovia chunk blows up and
falls to earth Ultron walks up in a new
drone body and chats with vision leading
to this fascinating chat about humanity
in the perspective of two androids
humans are odd they think order and
chaos are somehow opposites and try to
control what won't
it ends with vision using the mind stone
to blast Ultron which we see from a
distance now it's worth noting that
Ultron throughout this film is a
disembodied consciousness who hops
around among various drone bodies the
way you know which drone is Ultron at
any given moment is the red glowing eyes
they're all Ultron technically about the
red eyes equals Spader which made it
quite interesting a few years later in
spider-man homecoming when Spiderman
trapped in the storage facility rummaged
through Adrian Toomes stolen tech to
find an Ultron head with glowing red
eyes that's awesome yes Peter it is
awesome because while this Easter Egg
might have just been thrown in as a joke
this is the MCU
wherever Easter Egg is a future plot
point but how could all Tron have
survived I will dig into how but before
I continue thinking to rage shadow
legends for sponsoring this episode
Reed is the brand new free to play
collection RPG game that will knock your
socks off or if you're not wearing socks
you can put them on and it will not come
off it's got this awesome bullyboys
story campaign and over 400 champions
across 16 heroic factions that you can
collect and customize just look how
insanely detailed these champions are I
like this lady she's got her like sneeze
guard there as you know it's flu season
it's always good to have someone
covering them out and both she and her
friend have this like mist thing going
on you know to keep the air humid you
know hey this guy it's got some like a
Spider Man pattern going on in his armor
everybody could be rate is growing super
fast with almost 10 million players
worldwide who have downloaded the game
in less than six months and you know
have to take it for me there are more
than 380,000 reviews and almost a
perfect score and a play store the
game's highly anticipated faction Wars
features now live and there's a new
great rewards program for new players
and get a daily log and reward for the
first 90 days in the game so what are
you waiting for go down to the
description click on these special links
to download raid and you will instantly
get 800,000 silver and a 3 epic champion
lightsworn oh it's cool yeah and some
amazing ratings there but this package
will only be available for 30 days so
good luck and I'll see you there
ok back to how Ultron could have
survived rewatch an age of Ultron some
have pointed out the moment an Ultron
drone flies into Nick Fury's Helicarrier
fury and Maria hill put it down but the
drone could have had time to implant a
virus in fury server and have part of
its consciousness lay dormant as a
contingency in case he lost his battle
which he did from there Ultron could
have lived on in spare parts boxes with
scraps in storage and win Avengers HQ
got demolished in the Battle of Earth an
in-game those parts got littered across
upstate New York without Tony Stark
alive to make sure they were disposed of
properly and in the final moments of
endgame we even saw helicopters lifting
cargo away from the battlefield who the
hell are those guys
where they going is the pilot an Android
we don't know another way Ultron could
still be alive is through the vessel
that he always intended to live on
through a vision visions body was
designed to be an Ultron 2.0 a perfect
godly unbeatable specimen but Ultron's
AI download was interrupted with stark
and banner later downloading Jarvis's AI
into the body instead to create paul
bettany vision but the anatomy and
makeup of vision hasn't really been that
clear like affinity war it wasn't clear
how much of his soul was in the mine
stone or in Jarvis's AI or in his
vibranium atom infused flesh some of us
believe he has no soul but he is at
least part all Tron it's interesting
that Ultron's death be a vision happens
from a distance we don't know exactly
what goes down when Ultron leaps at him
the closes we ever get to an Ultron
corpse is the head that Spider Man pulls
out of that duffel bag if Ultron isn't
living on it boxes of scraps
what if vision absorbed whatever was
left of Ultron's essence wrapping him
inside his head as a prisoner to protect
him from getting out and from there
forward just doing his best to ignore
the voice of James Spader as he went
about his business making Pepper cash
fighting in airports and jet-setting
with Wanda around Scotland remember that
Ultron always seemed to have a soft spot
for Wanda Maximoff you
you'll die and it isn't until after
Wanda rips his heart out that her new
rebound heart's vision swoops into
romantically cradle her as if he's
picking up right where Ultron left off
and an Ultron a missions final
conversation they recognize each other's
parallel existences I suppose we have
both disappointments as far as we are
perhaps all the human complexes that
evolved inside visions head from there
forward are actually manifestations of
Ultron's presence in his mind his
affection for Wanda the way he tried to
imprison and control Wanda like a doll
in a dollhouse his misfire that almost
killed Rhodey if it was even a misfire
his haunting nightmares that he
discussed at the beginning of infinity
war probably narrated by Spader's
silky-smooth tongs and as Ultron warned
Wanda in age of Ultron when the earth
starts to settle God throws a stone at
it so does vision warn Wanda a few years
later when talking about his stones is
if it's piqued remember after Thanos
ripped out that stone at the end of this
film we never saw what happened with
visions Android body
Wanda dusts it away and there appear to
be no burial for vision which makes
sense he had no soul androids do not get
funerals but the VFX artists behind
spider-man far from home recently
revealed that when looking for visual
references to animate zombie Iron Man
and mysterious illusion sequence they
resurrected in a sense the precise
designs of Ultron the way he and its
drones amputated bodies relentlessly
drag themselves forward refusing to die
could these Framestore artists who work
on many of the Marvel films including
endgame have a similar visual in the
works for Ultron's resurrection picture
it a headstone for vision and Android
arm bursting from the earth and a gray
vision head but with glowing red Ultron
eyes
how do you think Ultron could return in
the MCU comment down below with your
thoughts and help free me from this
temporary blue dungeon into a new home
to make these marble deep dives even
better by becoming a patron of new
rockstars Digital Studios where you can
get early access to videos and an
exclusive monthly breakdown for all
these details just check out the link
below follow me on instagram and twitter
at EA vas thank you for joining me and
believe me I know at James Spader's
voice in your head sounds like cuz he's
always been up there
[Music]